hello everyone and welcome to the clash
you've all been waiting for it's round
nine of the 2022 tata steel chess
masters and it's magnus cross and versus
shakti arma medyarov both of them are
currently leading the tournament or
rather they are co-leading the
tournament and if any of them uh wins
the match if it's not drawn then that's
gonna be uh really huge for the for the
tournament standings so uh mamadirov
himself a former member member of the
2800 club is definitely no pushover he
is the last person to defeat magnus
carlsen in in a classical game uh he has
the black pieces here will he be able to
defend off magnus with white and uh
most of the times when when magnus plays
against someone they play not to lose
against him but mamadyarov often placed
the beat magnus and that's why the games
are uh
well much more interesting as you'll see
in this one and this one is no exception
it's a brilliant game um well let's dive
straight into it magnus with the white
pieces opens with d4 as he does in every
game uh knight to f6 we have knight to
f3 and now d5 we have c4 uh e6 going for
the queen's gambit declined and magnus
yet again goes for the catalan he plays
g3
we have d characters on c4 this is
nowadays the
the popular reply bishop to g2 and the
bishop to b4 with check we have bishop
the d2 blocking uh and now mamijarov
defends it with a5 and it seems like you
could mess up the black spawns a little
bit if you capture here but this is uh
this is actually perfectly fine for
black so white never does this here
magnus just castles uh although uh
instead of castling you could play queen
to c1 it's also a super popular move and
it's a very important one to know if you
play the catalan so i will show the idea
uh bishop captures on d2 knight captures
on the two now going after the c for
pawn and once black defends this it's
fine you don't have
any good discoveries here so
it's fine for black to play d5 we're
gonna challenge the c4 pawn here and
after captures we're gonna capture with
knight captures on b3 and now black has
to make a choice
uh black really wants to play bishop to
b7 but if he plays bishop to b7 uh then
he allows queen to g5 with this double
threat of queen captures and g7 and
queen captures on b5 and then for
example castle's queen captures on b5 is
very nice for white and if he doesn't
play bishop to b7 if he just castles
then we play knight to c5 and then we no
longer allow bishop to b7 so white has
just a lot of compensation here uh with
um
only white slide square bishop
controlling this beautiful diagonal and
this knight is wonderfully placed on c5
with no b-pawn or d-pawn available to
kick it away from there uh so that's
kind of the idea uh just in case you
guys were wondering but here magnus says
uh of course i know mom and dad knows
this we're not gonna play for tricks so
let's just nicely castle here um there
are also castles and now yeah usually
bishop to g5 and queen to c2 are the
moves that are played here but magnus
goes for the very rare e3 move he closes
his bishop here and now it's mamedyarov
to move uh mamadirov plays rook to a6
that brings the rook into the game also
very useful to get it away from this
diagonal and now again there is a a game
where a4 was played where you kind of
played this to prevent b5 but magnus
plays queen to c2 he develops the queen
puts pressure on the c for pawn and now
invites black to play b5 so he can
undermine it later on with a4 and it is
now as of move nine that we have a
completely new game so let's see b5 by
mommy darf now it's perfectly fine the
rook left the a8 square uh a4
challenging the b5 pawn and now c6 by
mamidyar we have knight to c3
putting more pressure on the b5 pawn and
here rook to b6 now defending the pawn
here but also this is uh very very
dangerous because if the position opens
up then look at the bishop ended the
rook here going after that a5 pawn and
the rook aligned with the queen on this
diagonal could be a very unpleasant but
interestingly this is exactly what
mamadyarov is counting on so here
carlson strikes in the center with e4 he
wants to play e5 kick away the knight
from the f6 square and then he might
have some very nice attacking chances
bishop back to e7 uh a very a very uh
suspicious retreat here by mamidyarov
that allows uh
well
or maybe it's not maybe he just wanted
magnus to go after the exchange so here
mamadira played bishop to e7 we have e5
challenging the knight knight to d5 and
now as this opened up like we've
discussed not just a characters on b5 so
here we have c characters and b5 uh
again knight to b4 is the sound approach
here you attack the queen and only once
the queen moves you play c captures on
b5 uh but mahmoud wants to beat magnus
with the black pieces he plays c
captures on b5 and he sacrifices the
exchange so magnus accepts it knight
captures on the e5 e captures on the e5
and now bishop captures an a5 now of
course the rook cannot move the queen is
on d8 so knight to c6 attacking the
bishop bishop captures and queen
captures
so what did momidarov gain for this uh
exchange well uh he gained uh the
possibility of playing b4 and c3
creating a pass pawn here on the queen
side he still has the bishop paired the
rook and may be placed on c8 and you're
gonna play uh with this uh past c pawn
hopefully or maybe a pass b pawn depends
on how the situation unfolds and
hopefully white will have to give back
the exchange at some point and it's
gonna be perfectly fine but it will give
you something to play for so here magnus
plays rook to a8 a very nice rook lift
of course if the the bishop moves we're
going to trade off a pair of rooks and
then we're going to
see what happens there mamadara plays h6
here takes away the g5 square from uh
from
the white knight and now magnus plays
rook f2a1 uh there was a lot of
discussion here that there's a really
disgusting engine line that we are going
to discuss as we usually do on this
channel uh that starts with rook
captures on c8 but um uh it kind of
seems that what magnus played was it was
even nicer in the long run but here the
idea behind rook captures on c8 is rook
captures on c8 and now queen f5
attacking the undefended rook and c8 and
preparing this e6 push so look back to
f8 we're gonna play e6 now attacking the
the f7 square uh and also just the the
d5 pawn but now knight to b4 defending
this d5 pawn and threatening queen
captures an e6 so e captures an f7 with
check rook captures now queen g4
uh and now uh for example bishop to f6
we put pressure on on this pawn here
also we do not want to allow knight to
e5 and here rook to e1 so what can black
play well let's say queen to d8 and now
we play knight to e5 and the idea behind
all of it is captures captures and now
white has a past e pawn that's gonna be
extremely strong so that's kind of the
idea behind giving back the exchange but
magnus plays a rook after a1 uh he keeps
the exchange and he now allows
mamidyarov to uh to figure out the game
plan and the best for mamadara would be
to simply go what he was uh trying to
achieve this whole time b4 and then we
we try and create a pass pawn and well
it's not as simple as that but that is
the the best approach here however he
played bishop to e6 here and now uh as
of this moment it's move 19 uh magnus
plays every move according not just to a
computer but according to a super
computer as we do have access to this
essay analyzing uh everything uh so here
he starts with queen to d1 and queen to
d1 uh just uh you know so you can soak
that in uh is uh not an easy move to
spot but once once you know why it's
played then it becomes obvious so the
idea behind a queen to d1 is let's say
black plays bishop to g4 we want to have
uh the queen to be able to come to a1
now for example h3 bishop to h5 we're
going to play rook captures on f8 bishop
captures and now this very nice rook to
a8 idea pinning the bishop and once
queen b7 is played now we want to move
the queen queen to a1 and we keep the a
file for a rook with an incredible
pressure
across the entire board so that's the
idea
but
you don't have to play this you could
play pretty much anything with black but
nothing will be nothing will be as as
good so here mamadirov played b4 uh kind
of the move that he he should have
played a move earlier but this is so
hard to imagine uh even um uh you know
grandmasters in the live coverage said
that they they don't really believe that
the position is so much better for white
but uh
obviously magnus agrees with with the
super computer the situation on the
clock if you guys are wondering 55
minutes for magnus 45 minutes for for
mom and dad after this b4 move was
played but now magnus is completely
winning so feel free to pause the video
and try to find this incredible
continuation while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh well inhuman move to play and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show the movie is pawn to b3 that's the
good stuff we actually invite black to
create a passport with c3 so
congratulations to everyone who who
found this you are uh an excellent
supporter of super computer ideas uh so
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show uh
b3 was the move so momodaro of course
advances his pawn to c3 he says thank
you for this past pawn and it seems like
black has all the compensation in the
world but now rook 8 to a6 again the
only winning continuation for magnus and
it really uh
you will now see see what happens with
the position so here we have queen back
to c7 you have to play something queen
to c7 queen to b7 we have to keep an eye
on our knight here and then now comes
knight to e1 another only moved for
magnus that magnus very nicely spots the
knight now has to come the c2 the e3 and
from e3 will have excellent pressure on
d5 also you will have support for f4 f5
the knight is just
just a monster here and the idea is that
uh also it's uh
just unstoppable for example black could
try bishop to g5 with the idea of bishop
to d2 uh but it doesn't matter for
example h3 bishop to d2 we're gonna move
the knight back attack the bishop and
once the bishop moves we're just going
to chase it away after the bishop goes
back now we just repeat 91 knight to c2
knight to e3 and we continue playing and
black does not have a single move to
play the the knight hasn't got anywhere
to go the bishop is upon basically the
dark square bishop know where to go the
queen the rook everything is completely
tied down there is nothing to play here
really so allowing mommy thereof to
get this advancement with the c3 move
basically locked the position down
completely and now black is without a
move so after this knight to the e1
movement doesn't even try this he plays
f6 trying to mess up the the central uh
structure here but now uh it's again
completely crushing although now magnus
has to switch plans now it's no longer
knight to c2 to e3 now it's knight to d3
now the e5 square will open up and the
knight belongs uh on the e5 square as
you'll see mamadou burns his time like
crazy here he's already down to 15
minutes on the clock and he plays f
captures an e5 just to show you uh how
deadly knight the d3 is i will show you
the absolute best defense for black g5
uh and after white captures on f6 we're
gonna play rook captures on f6 and now
knight to e5 and there's no defense here
whatever you play loses uh best for
black is knight captures an e5 but now
we play d captures on e5 attack the rook
and after queen captures now we just
captured the bishop on e6 and it doesn't
matter you can capture with the rook
bishop captures on d5 the rook cannot
move uh and there's nothing you can do
if you try the tricky c2 okay we attack
the rook and the queen uh we just pick
up the rook with check
once the queen moves we can pick up the
c2 pawn the queen no longer attacks the
rook here so the c2 push doesn't really
do anything you're gonna have to move
the queen queen d6 but now just let's
say bishop captures queen captures let's
say rook a7 and black will get
checkmated very very quickly there's
really no counter play here so instead
after knight to d3 mirror picks up the
e5 pawn right away but now knight
captures on e5 and again what do you
play here the knight is hanging if you
move the knight the bishop is hanging if
you try knight to d8 it doesn't really
work we still just capture on e6 and
after knight captures bishop captures on
d5 uh what do you play here queen to d6
you're gonna guard the knight now comes
bishop c4 with rook to a6 coming there's
no defending this position also knight
the g6 in some variations uh complete
annihilation here so after knight
captures on e5 mamadarav captured on e5
but now just rook captures an e6
attacking the knight here attacking the
bishop here bombay thereof played c2 uh
just uh check what magnus will play here
but after queen to e1 he was in this
position on move 27 that uh shakhtar
mahmoud resigned the game and what a
spectacular victory for magnus carlsen
in round nine of the tata steel
tournament against uh
well a former 2800 member himself
shakira mamayarov so really uh
incredible stuff and the idea is that
after well you have to play something
let's say bishop g5 we're gonna pick up
the knight here now create a pass pawn
here and black does not have a good move
maybe just
winning the exchange here is best for
black and after let's say bishop
captures we're going to capture on d5
threat and all sorts of nasty
discoveries once black mitigates this
we're going to play queen captures on b4
and there's nothing the rook is hanging
after the queen defends the rook we're
just going to play queen to c5 defend
our bishop and that's it let's say
bishop goes back we're going to play b
for b5 b6 b7 and the b pawn just wins
the game if you try to stop the beep on
then the e pawn wins the game there
there's nothing to play here so of
course mamiyarov knows this and after
queen to e1 and move 27 uh he resigned
the game uh so where did where did
mahmoud go wrong it's hard to say maybe
the whole idea of the exchange sacrifice
is uh
interesting but against uh
against perfect play it also requires
perfect play for for you to hold the
position and such was the case in this
game where maybe
uh after this uh uh
well maybe all the way back rook f2a1
where magnus allowed mamadar of this uh
uh this uh small window of opportunity
instead of going for that rook captures
on c8 line that we've discussed maybe b
for right away and then uh black does
not lose any valuable temp with bishop
to e6 and the the the game continues but
uh this way magnus played it perfectly
and mahmoud allowed like i said this one
window of opportunity
uh and that's it that's all it took so
incredible incredible game uh but also
something that i mentioned mentioned in
the beginning of the video uh mamadourov
does not play for equality against
magnus like most players he always plays
uh daring lines he wants to beat magnus
doesn't matter if it's with white or
black and that's the kind of chess that
we enjoy watching and then also magnus
will get a chance and if he you know
finds the absolute best line then he
wins if he doesn't then it's a draw or
or he loses like we mentioned that
mamidor is the last person to beat uh
magnus in classical time format so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
really really a wild one uh uh i would
like to thank david kimura thomas earl
trevor futado souza guyan khan and
william rose for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this amazing
tournament until it ends uh so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day